a lot of people talking about showing up
and people denigrating on my showing up
rule it is ladies and gentlemen not 80
percent of success regardless what
anyone tells you it is probably more
like
99.9 of success and anybody that says
otherwise is just trying to get some
attention unnecessarily because I
already love all you guys check it out
like if you don't show up you have no
chance of anything happening and once
you show up physically show up and you
being freaking unbelievable Superstar
but if you don't show up for the
audition the sales call the speak you
did if you don't show up and buy that
lottery ticket you can't win it then you
got to get a little lucky then you got
to persist then you got to do all the
other things you got to do first you've
got to show up people don't show up for
one of three reasons number one is
you're afraid you're afraid of rejection
you're afraid of failure you're afraid
of it not working out until you just
don't show up number two is you're not
consistent you show up some days but you
don't show up other days because you
don't have the routines and habits in
place to make you show up consistently
every single day and number three is you
don't want to you don't want to show up
because you don't actually enjoy the
thing that you're about to do you would
rather procrastinate on it because you
don't love it and showing up is more
painful than just sitting around so my
goal today with this video is to help
you bust through these so that you can
show up for life and have the impact
that you want to have so I think the
fear of showing up is actually a good
thing it means that you are doing
something different something outside
your comfort zone something that is that
is not normal that is new and that's
good you want to be pushing the envelope
if there was nothing that you are afraid
to show up to today tomorrow next week
then you're not growing you're not
learning you're not pushing against your
boundaries and comfort zones and so even
today I had to show up but and again it
should be every single day so today I
was procrastinating on sending out an
email to Grant as well as a couple other
people where I'm looking at doing more
collaborations more work on my YouTube
channel more cross pollination
connection to other successful YouTubers
to help the whole entrepreneur YouTube
Community grow right I want to get the
message out there I want to be playing a
bigger game and so I emailed Grant and
emailed for the people with a new idea
that I had so when the idea was first
suggested to me about doing this and
reaching out I had a little bit of
nerves like okay okay it's gonna require
an ask I might get rejected it may not
work out and I had it scheduled for
today because today was my YouTube day
and so I look at the list today I'm like
ah maybe I should start with one person
or two people or just pick the easy
people
and just the fact that I felt that just
the fact that that was one of the
reasons meant I had to go and do five I
had to do a bigger number I had to go
after the harder people I had to do the
people that I thought
may say yes may say no may make me look
bad if they say no and a lot of it is
just head games
the honest truth is Grant's probably not
going to care Grant's probably gonna say
yes like 98 chance he says yes and he
passes on to somebody on his team we
start working together and we create the
collaboration uh one percent chance he
ignores it and one percent chance he
says no
but it's not the logical rational things
that hold us back it's the emotional
fearful things and so what I've trained
myself to do is anytime I feel that that
that oh my God it may not work out then
I have to do it I have to do it I have
just to show myself because the worst
thing you can do is get to the edge of
the cliff and say you're gonna jump and
then not jump It's better not to catch
that you're nervous it's better not to
even come up with the idea to just float
around in ignorance ignorance is bliss
than to catch it and then play small and
so as soon as you catch it I've trained
myself I want you to do the same thing
as soon as you catch it train yourself
to do it even if it doesn't work out
just training yourself that you don't
back down when you are afraid so I'm
going to give you a three-step process
you can follow to help you conquer your
fears to help you show up consistently
every day let's do it number one is tell
yourself that you do scary things one of
the biggest reasons why people don't
Advance their ideas forward is because
it's scary it's scary you're afraid
amazing that is now no longer an
acceptable reason you do scary things
you love scary things you Embrace scary
things you want to do scary things
this isn't just a mindset trick it's
actually true you want to do scary
things you do what's the opposite of
scary things the opposite of scare if
you walk through life and you're never
scared of anything it's not that you're
super confident no it means that you're
living inside your comfort zone it means
you're only doing things that have zero
fear that you have absolute certainty in
because you've done it before
you're bored you're living inside your
bubble and you need to break out because
that means you're photocopying your life
every single day if there's nothing in
your calendar that makes you scared you
hate your life and so pay attention to
the language pay attention to how you
talk to yourself pay attention to when
you feel afraid
and as long as it's not against your
code of ethics or doing something stupid
don't go jump out of an airplane without
a parachute because you're afraid
right most of the things you're afraid
of are not life-threatening
teach yourself that you do scary things
you love scary things and you're not
allowed to use as an excuse anymore for
not taking action number two is think
what makes you sore what is the thing
that gets you feeling bold alive
confident ready to take action wanting
to show up to life what is it I go
through five s's every morning as part
of my morning routine the versus sing
and then sun and then soar and then
sweat and then scare the most important
part is sore though it's a thing that I
do to make me come alive that makes me
want to soar and so for me what I do is
I think about an entrepreneur that I
helped yesterday and then I pull up my
phone and then I record a message and I
share that to my YouTube stories
Instagram stories Twitter LinkedIn I put
it everywhere
I need to feel like the work that I do
matters right now I'm just talking to a
camera I'm just talking into a camera
right now and and later it's gonna be
edited and it's gonna be thrown up on
YouTube and lots of people are going to
watch the video that's that's crazy it's
hard to imagine because I'm just sitting
here in my office talking into a camera
and so I need to remember that the work
I do has purpose that this matters to
some people right that people rely on my
videos every day as a part of their
routine
and that helps make me soar so I wake up
just like everybody else I'm tired I'm I
don't know what time it is sometimes
even this morning I woke up I didn't
even know what day it was is it the
weekend is it I had no idea right you
wake up I'm not coming out of the day
scene yeah oh my gosh let's go right
that's not how anybody wakes up nobody
that's not how Grant Cardone wakes up
Evan Carmichael Tony Robbins nobody
that's not how we wake up the difference
is the habits that you set on a daily
basis to demand that success to demand
that you show up
and so what is the thing that helps make
you sore maybe it's remembering the
impact you want to have maybe it's
sharing a message to YouTube to
Instagram to LinkedIn maybe it's doing
an active service maybe it's meditation
maybe it's reading maybe it's watching
these videos what is it that makes you
feel like you want to soar and then
don't randomly hope that it happens
demand that is part of your morning
routine because if you woke up and did
the thing to make you sore to make you
feel bold confident Unstoppable and you
did that every day for the next year
your life will be dramatically different
you will not recognize the person who
you used to be
the challenge is you're not consistent
in soaring and so I need you to make
that part of your morning routine and
then number three is understand what is
your Michael Jordan Talent what could
you be the greatest in the world at you
could be the greatest the greatest of
all time at something you are but what
is that thing most people are living way
below the potential because they settled
you settled too early you settled
because you were pressured you settled
because you were afraid you settled
because you ran out of time or at least
you felt you did that's not an
acceptable answer anymore you could be
the greatest in the world at something
and if you're procrastinating on
something it's either because you're
afraid of the thing in which case you
need to go and do it because you do
scary you do afraid right back to tip
number one or two you just don't like it
you procrastinate because you don't like
it and if you continue to do work that
you don't like
you're never going to be the best
because you're going up against people
who love it who love it
who love it
right if you're going up to play
basketball against Michael Jordan you
better love the game as much as he does
or you're gonna lose if it's just a
strategy for you you're gonna lose and
so look at the thing that's in front of
you look at the thing that you are not
showing up for it's for one of those
three reasons either you're afraid to do
it and therefore you must do it or two
you don't have consistent habits in
which case you need to put the thing
that makes you soar into your morning
routine or three you just don't actually
want to do it and stop forcing yourself
to do it go off and find the thing that
you have Michael Jordan level Talent at
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
my wealth ultimately is not the money I
have it's the knowledge I have and the
belief I have in myself the same thing
for you but I want to take you on this
trip because look number one you got to
visualize it you got to be able to see
it in your mind like possibility second
thing is you got to see it you know in
the physical Universe you can explain to
me what a bougainvillea is you can
explain to me what a beach is you can
explain to me what uh the gym looks like
on the second floor in Cabo San Lucas at
this beautiful hotel we're at but until
I visually visually physically put
an image to the ocean to the whales to
the sunshine to the mountains until I
visually see it it doesn't become real
third thing you want to do number one
see it in your mind
I was I was doing a call today with
Percy Miller uh Master P and he's like
first thing you got to do is see it in
your mind he grew up in extreme poverty
in the projects and he says Grant first
thing I had to do was I had to see it in
my mind that I could get out second
thing I had to do was see a picture of
it in the physical Universe
uh that's how valuable the internet is
today is that you get to see things that
maybe are way outside your price range
you can see the lambo the rolls the big
house the trip you can see the
possibility of Elon going to Mars you
know and and all of a sudden all those
things expand possibilities so number
one you got to see it in your mind too
you got to see it in the physical
universe and this also includes other
people examples of other people that are
doing great things I'm not just talking
about physical manifestation I'm not
talking about stuff I'm not talking
about watches and bracelets and rings
and houses and cars I'm talking about
how can you actually manifest something
in the real world that you have in your
mind how do you turn an idea
into reality
and these things that I'm sharing with
you'll make it a possibility when you
dig deep on them though it's like okay
well how do I get closer to people that
are doing those things because the third
thing is you got to get closer to the
thing you want if you want a gulf stream
or if you want to solve the water
problem of planet Earth you're going to
have to get closer physically closer
step on not just see with your eyes in a
magazine or on the Internet you need to
put your feet in the sand put your feet
on the jet
now that might mean that you got to go
fuel jets for a while you got to go work
at an aviation company an airport and
actually fuel them clean them wash them
maybe you got to be a flight attendant
on them put your feet next to them maybe
you have to become a pilot you're going
to have to pay the price though there's
no free lunch here for anybody including
my children there's no free lunch
there's no way to know what this room
feels like the expansiveness of this
room by looking at on the internet the
moment you can get in it it'll be become
even more real to you the fourth thing
is you got to put your feet in this deal
you got to put your feet in this deal
there's a there's a horse down there I
can you can visualize a horse you can
seat a horse you you gotta touch the
horse in the fourth thing I'm sorry you
got to touch the hearts and the fourth
thing is you guys got to collaborate
with other people man you got to get in
the room with other people whether
you're serving water
if they don't invite you to sit down
then offer them money to sit down with
them if that doesn't work
um offer to serve them to sit down okay
this is a story of my life could be
wrapped up in these four things right
here number one see it in my mind number
two see it in the physical Universe like
see it in in some not physical but in
metaverse on the internet in a magazine
a picture of it third get closer to it
put your feet on it on the plane on the
horse on the beach in the hotel if I got
to go work there to do it and the fourth
thing is you got to network with people
that have stuff okay again uh I spent
some time this week with uh Dame Dash
she's like look you got to get close to
the action you got to get with the
people that are making the moves you
cannot make the moves from your own
neighborhood uh Percy Miller tell me you
cannot make the moves from the projects
you got to move from the projects and I
make the moves in the project quit
working street corners quit selling just
a product and start hanging out with
people that have scaled their think
their ideas into a reality this isn't a
magic act these are basic skills
and basic skills are duplicatable
and the reason most salespeople have
such trouble is because for years we
have been trying sales professionals and
the gurus have been teaching uh
manipulation tactics
Dodge the question
don't answer control the customer uh the
the whole neuro Linguistics book
these are gimmicks we have never hired
one person that had a neuro-linguistics
background that worked for us
successfully
so you guys are in the NLP stuff I'm
just telling you we've hired hundreds
and hundreds of sales people I've been
with tens of thousands of sales people I
have never seen one
person that got into this neural bull
that was a successful salesperson over
long periods of time and did not bring
drama to our organization
I don't want drama dude I want
production
so so when when he sits a certain way I
don't start thinking about man
um imagine being in a sales sales
presentation I'm like I got to be like
him and then now I got to be like her
and now I got to be like him guess who
you can't be when you're doing that you
you man what a dis
S I want to be me the power resonates
from me my truth my authenticity and my
transparency
Okay so
if you can't do that you can't build you
can't build a business and you certainly
can't duplicate it I never ask him to be
me I'm like hey bro when somebody says
the payments are too high what do you do
what do you say well I'm with you
everybody try that
no no I didn't say it like that I said
I'm with you
see and I'm with you
hey man hey the price is too high I knew
that before you did
everybody try that
okay CeCe he gets to be him but the
words will work because all I'm doing is
basically agreeing with the customer
this isn't a trick here okay uh this
course is uh I'm doing a dinner tonight
for 25 000 at my house okay I think we
got two slots left
the entire 25 000 goes to the Grant
Cardone Foundation any of you want to
put 25 Grand in please see one of my
people come have dinner at my house
we'll spend a couple hours over there
the money's going to go to help kids
some of you in the room immediately say
oh my God 25 Grand that's a lot of money
man I know that
you don't think I know twenty five
thousand dollars is a lot of money I'm
the one that decided what the freaking
entry would be
I said what would be too much 25 Grand
25 Grand would be a lot of damn money
somebody gonna be like that damn that's
a lot of money okay and the people that
it's a lot of money that think small
that go small and don't want to help
won't come to my house and have dinner
and the people they're like dude I'd go
spend two hours with that cat man for 25
Grand to get pictures with him at his
new home with his family
with with eight or ten other people and
the money's going to charity and I get
to write it off I get to bang the IRS
who hates the IRS
yeah
well this is this is the chance to give
them a good friend
[Music]
you see what I'm doing I'm handling all
the objections right now I understand 25
Grand is a lot of money man I know what
you got to do to earn 25 Grand you got
to do crazy stuff to earn 25 Grand and
if you keep thinking that earning 25
Grand is always going to be a problem
for you hopefully for everybody in the
room one day you're going to be able to
earn 25 000 every hour all commitments
require investments in time and money
all commitments you cannot make a
commitment without time and money being
invested time and money has to be
invested you have to invest time and
money if it's not on your schedule
you're not committed if you don't have
money back by that time on your calendar
if it's not costing you money or you
don't have money deposited right there
you are not committed where you have
your money is where your personal
spiritual emotional physical commitments
go whatever your money is is who you are
most committed to
Wells Fargo Bank of America Citibank
you guys many of you got more money at
Wells Fargo than you have invested in
your own advertise in the market
because you guys are committed to the
live the Big Marketing scam of the
universe
save your money
save your money
what you should do is you should get a
good job first of all you should
avoid borrowing money
unless it's for something that we think
is good for you
right
so first of all you should not borrow
money unless
it's one of our credit cards
where we give you points
one day
able to stay at a Holiday Inn for free
where by the way the buffets at the
kitchen are free you can eat all you
want not to mention that you're already
overweight but you could go there and
eat all you want for as long as you want
butter
if you just borrow enough money on this
card
to buy enough stuff you don't need
to pay us back one day if you can
right and then during the week when
you're not borrowing money from us what
you should do is spend your time getting
money to pay for the brand that belt
that you bought and put on your credit
card
that you can't write off about it so
this is what Americans are doing people
all around the world spend 40 hours a
week running around hustling
yeah they get a hundred dollars what do
they do now they run over here to the
bank drop off the hundred bucks then
they run back out do another 40 weeks
pick up a thousand dollars man I had a
great week didn't I bang and then they
run over here and drop it off at the
bank these are the good Americans
the bad Americans go pick up a thousand
bucks and go to the club and blow it
the good Americans run run around
collecting a thousand dollars five
thousand dollars ten thousand dollars
Hustlers Hustlers man hard workers they
they get sophisticated ugh I'm gonna put
a little money in the bank over here
over here at Wells Fargo I'm gonna have
a little over here at the Citibank I'ma
spread this sh around
I want to be a slave to many not a slave
to a few
I'm going to give a little to Bank of
America I'm going to give a little bit
to Citibank I'm gonna give a little bit
to the Wells Fargo I'm going to give a
little bit to Fidelity and Merrill Lynch
I'm going to give a little bit to my IRA
and my 401k I'm going to bust my ass I'm
gonna spend 40 years killing myself to
make sure all these institutions
my money
where they pay me nothing
for the sake of security
right and then you guys look up one day
you're like where's my money at it's in
all these accounts by the way what do
those people do with your money when
they get it
they call me up
hey Mr Cardone
we got another dummy
guy spent goddamn he must have spent 160
hours put together a little Bank
extremely disciplined dumbass
and he saved hundred thousand dollars
with us and we'd like to know Mr Cardone
if you would like to borrow that money
his money
yeah I sure would because we know Mr
Cardone that you'll put that money to
work
okay this guy that gave it to us all he
wants to do is work
I'm like yes send me that money bro send
me that money okay and they by the way
they're not done calling me they're
going to call nine other people
they're going to take his 100 Grand and
they're going to say they're gonna
they're gonna lend it out nine hundred
thousand dollars of it and this is the
banking system
and that is debt by the way
that U.S dollar
okay they're basically multiplying money
if the bank doesn't keep it why do you
spend all your time giving it to them
to keep for you I've been extremely like
the theme that runs in my life is just
disappointment throughout the whole
thing particularly the first from 50
from 10 years old to 25.
and then 25 to 50 you know yeah I was
doing better because I I had a drug
problem in 16. oh you did yeah was that
the disappointment or was it like no no
no no the drugs were just the drugs were
a byproduct you know it was the
disappointment was
uh you know
the school thing school was
disappointing no uncles no dad right no
I didn't know Direction Just boredom
that's why what you do with these race
the races at least keep somebody
occupied for some moment of time that
gives them a goal big enough and a
challenge sure I didn't have any
challenges you didn't have anybody like
setting some goals up in front of you no
no when my dad died I kept waiting for
one of the uncles to step up and they
didn't kind of and that pissed me off
because I'm like dude somebody's got to
step up and give me a little guidance
here but you but you had older um
Brothers my older brother died when I
was 20. right so 10 years after my dad
died so there was no men got a just a
bunch of women and my mom wasn't like
setting big goals for you no no my mom
my mom my mom grew up in bread lines so
right you know I'd go to my mom I
remember I did a deal when I was 30.
bought my first piece of Real Estate
and um Mom I bought this piece of real
estate it was three million dollars a
1.9 million dollars and she's like well
that's great but you know I just I love
you just the way you are right and I
hung up the phone she said that to me a
thousand times
and I hope the phone said yeah but I
don't love me the way I am and then the
my counselor buddy Dale says You Need To
Love Yourself the way you are I said
ain't never gonna happen
right I said that's the big lot I don't
want to love me the way I don't want to
become the guy I should be from 15 to 25
I was using drugs every day so when I
tell you
hey you can do anything
I was a
habitual daily drug user
overdose three times
was brought back by people just
wandering into a room saying oh this
guy's in trouble
okay I don't know if I was trying to
kill myself at the time or I was just
didn't know what I was doing or stupid
or whatever like
I was a walking time bomb and I was not
to be trusted by my family by my friends
there was no one in my life between 15
and 25 that I could have a positive
influence on
I was a liability
to everyone in my life including my
family
and my friends and people I went to
school with and the places I worked at I
lost seven jobs in a row I was
unemployable
25 I went to a treatment center and said
I got to turn this around
I got to turn this around I cannot keep
using drugs they're bad for me I make
poor decisions when I'm using them I I
go out with the wrong people hang with
the wrong people end up in the wrong
fights I literally got like when you're
using drugs you're going to pick fights
You Can't Win not in a lifetime
you're gonna get in the wrong cars make
the wrong decisions the wrong purchases
and you're going to miss a lot of great
opportunities so first thing is you
can't do great things
if you're incapable of making great
decisions and when you're under the
influence
and I don't want to preach to you I'm
just telling you what what advice I'd
give myself if I was on the comeback and
I was
15 years old and being influenced by
everybody smoking the Kush
it's cool now
it's probably going to be legal
everywhere
going out drinking on the weekends
forgetting everything that you did
and just making poor decisions so I'll
tell you hey you got you got to figure
out how how is that going to somehow
Advance your life you're going to have
to make some hard choices if I'm a young
guy coming up young gal coming up how
can I pick great relationships when
everybody's under the influence
and again I don't mean to sound like a
like a a preacher or anything because
I'm definitely not that we're going to
have a great time this weekend I'm here
for a week we're going to have a lot of
fun but I couldn't do that if I was
still under the influence every day how
many rooms are broke right now you're
broke you're like just dead broke like
like if I went and banged on your credit
card it would scream and call the police
no uh alert 9-1-1 call them out right
now this cannot be used again
that's fine dude that's fine you still
need to have your dreams
you need to start dreaming now how old
are you dude
22 years old you got any money at all
but he's got a little he's got a little
diamond in his ear right here he ain't
got any money but he's like look at this
[ __ ]
I'm signing I'm Shining
huh I'm excited to come here come here
man yeah come here man come here I'm
tired
I got a little cubic
[Applause]
come on up here man 22 years old man 22
years old you know what I was doing
every day 22 years old how what do you
weigh man how much you weigh oh you got
one in both ears look at this let's get
a close-up can you get a close-up look
at that man oh he's so cool he's so cool
look he looks good too man looks good
okay look how much money do you have to
your name
a thousand bucks
what
I feel like a million bucks though yeah
yeah
either way bro you broke
you agree with that oh yeah you're broke
you guys need to admit it you need to
own you need to know when you're broke
the man's got a thousand dollars
right he goes to jail today
he's broke
so so like but but that does not that
does not mean you can't dream
so right now what he's gonna do is his
dreams are gonna be like okay man like I
just wanna I just want to get a a two
grand
all right I just want to get some of
these
or I want to get a watch
dude that's not the dream folks
you know when you were a kid when you
were a kid 12 years old what do you want
you want a car I can't wait till I get
in the car you don't think about it I'm
gonna own a car dealership
do you think I want a car you don't
think hey man I'm gonna make a new car
that flies
right see that's why he ended up with
these little cubics
because his dreams aren't big enough get
off the stage
okay but he's in the right place he's in
the right place everybody agree
three years old you know I'll be 64 in
March and
you know I feel like I'm like 14 years
old man I'm like let's roll like let's
let's go I'm ready to run through walls
and you know fly and learn new stuff I'm
studying uh cryptos right now in the
metaverse and like what happens and when
do I make a play and do I make a play
and what is all this so you one number
one you have to stay curious
foreign
number one curious you have to be
curious when Clubhouse came around
Clubhouse is an audio app if you don't
know what that is
a couple years ago most of people in my
office including Jared was like man
ain't nothing there's nothing there
you know I'm like oh there's people
there though
there's people there and what I
discovered because I was curious about
Clubhouse is not because I was curious
about social media I was curious about
people
to me I get energy from people
and so
um I've been in rooms where uh Alan have
y'all met Alan yet
so Alan Alan saw me go in a room one
night and he texted me he's like what
the hell you doing in this room man and
I said what's up he's like get out of
this room
and I said what you worried about he's
like you're the only white person in the
room and the title is white entitlement
[Music]
and he sends me a little sweaty emoji
I said bro where how am I going to learn
about white entitlement with white
people
like you got to be curious folks just
because it has nothing to do with you
doesn't mean your Market's not there and
for me to be able to Market to a market
means I need to understand how that
market thinks
so one of the great benefits of me being
curious particularly about two-way
communication on on social media the
feedback
I'm not looking for likes and comments
I'm looking for something some
electricity in the moment what you're
talking about the drive potential
potential and idea like all my ideas
come from I don't fabricate ideas
everything you see me do happened it was
happening already in the universe
I don't I don't create anything I just
grab something that's already there
and I grab it out of something I hear
so the Supreme Court today announced
they kicked out the Mandate for the
vaccine I'm
[Applause]
okay good like it or don't like it you
all need to get on one side of that
story and start talking to people about
it so you gain that audience
you need to you need oh I don't want to
be
put man
you know there's nothing that raises
more money than politics
nothing there's nothing and most of it's
just a scam
and everybody knows that they're like
I'm throwing in they ain't throwing in
for their side they're throwing in to
keep the other side that they're worried
about the point of the story is there's
energy there there's tremendous amounts
of energy that you wanna you wanna tap
into if you could walk the line and play
both of them that'd be super cool
very difficult to do that though
so when that came out today I'm like
good job man like I got to take a stand
on that now will I lose some people 100
percent
I don't care who I lose there's eight
billion people on this planet I'm
worried about who doesn't know me
so the way to protect your brand
the way to protect your brand is to
expand it that's the only way to protect
your brain learn to discipline yourself
if you got to go to the gym every day if
you hate going to the gym go to the gym
I don't like going to the gym but I'm
like I don't like my body hurting either
sooner or later if you don't go to the
gym and work your body your body will it
will scream at you and it will hurt
lower back pains arms Shoulders Knees
you name it it's always going to hurt
and as long as this hurt and how can you
be fully available for the people around
you if your body's hurting two you got
to eat good foods okay got to make
decisions I ain't gonna eat junk
I'm not gonna eat the junk why why
because I'm saying no to junk if you can
start saying no to stuff
you can start saying yes to the good
things like my little girl right there
Sabrina say hi Sabrina
so pay the price today learn how to be
great at jobs you hate
that's paying the price get up early
go to bed early okay beat the Sun up
every morning it'll give you so much
confidence I'm paying the price when I
do that when I get up before the sun
gets up I'm paying the price when I go
to bed at nine o'clock and I'm not
watching TV and movies and just being
entertained and effect of whatever's
coming my way I'm paying the price when
I don't waste the weekends the weekends
make you weak listen to me cancer for
weak people
anything after 10 o'clock at night it's
for weak people
okay Saturday and Sunday staying up all
night weak people people are made weak
on the weekends pay the price okay give
up the weekends for the next five years
and Watch What Happens five years man
that's a lot of weekends that's what is
that 250 weekends is that right yeah 250
weekends that means I'm ahead of the
people around me
I'm paying the price today
in hopes that I could pay any price in
the future I have 12 employees I'm sure
at one point you had you know four or
five employees how did you go from four
or five to whatever you have now I had I
had two employees from the age of
29
[Music]
no no from the age of 30 to
38 years old I had two employees for
eight years
I did everything I was the secretary
phone answer
uh I did payroll stole from myself
did my taxes I did my own taxes I
wouldn't pay anybody anything
from
uh 30 to 38 38 to 45 added like two or
three people
[Music]
I was I was officing out of the guest
house
at my my my my place that I lived at in
in Los Angeles
[Music]
it was a dude it was an awesome hour
Lionel Richie lived in that house you
know is
it was a cool house right but it was
small thinking man I was still thinking
little
[Music]
and if you're going to stay small you're
going to get crushed
2009 2008 and 2009. so what eventually
made you say you know what I'm just
gonna make us
what happened was a guy told me years
before that that bigger is not better
and I believed it because he busted out
he busted out when he went big and he
says Graham bigger is not better man
stay small
and I and I believe that dude and I
carried it on a long time it's bad
advice knowledge is power
bad knowledge is to so what I did was I
stayed small till I was 45 years old
five employees I was one of them so four
and
um
when 2008 came I'm like this was stupid
dude like I got a scale
and and that was what 12 uh how many
years ago was that nine years seven or
eight years ago there was no jet
there was no big office it just shows
you man when you change your mind when
you change your mind and start like hey
I'm gonna scale this thing out I'm gonna
go Global I'm gonna have people know me
I'm gonna get attention I'm going to get
my products out I'm gonna lower my
prices I'm going to bring this thing to
Market I'm going to get big bring in
good people we have how many employees
we have now charity 72 at the office we
got our partners here tonight we got in
another 150 in uh in in the real estate
game we're going to expand that we'll
probably pick up another 12 or 15 this
month because the two more deals we're
bringing on and next year I'm talking
about going global so all everything
that happened everything has happened
really good to us has happened because
of the expansion you failed the business
no Problem
you restart another business
so the way to play this is let's go
ahead and give your business the best
shot
you need training you're going to need
sales you're going to need phone skills
you're going to need follow-up otherwise
it's going to fail okay now watch we put
it on a credit card
if we put it on a credit card and you
fail
the bankruptcy court picks up the Visa
Mastercard of the American Express
the training contract you you you did
with us lives on for your next company
you guys understand that 100 of those
people will continue on in some other
business
a few of them will commit suicide
okay I'm done
but the rest of them are gonna be like
[ __ ] I gotta go do something and they
are going to restructure and start
another company Donald Trump has
restructured casinos man this is not a
new thing like the big boys restructure
okay fail boom We restructure we'll
create something new I still got a
business okay you got to get this guy to
see this might fail but you won't
because you won't quit and you're going
to be over here I just had a coaching
call with some friends of mine they come
in every month and and they're working
on their business they're going to bust
a million dollars this month when I met
them they were literally the company was
not making money they're going to make a
million dollars they asked me a question
today that I want to talk about they're
like dude how are you
everybody we talked to talks about being
nice to their people taking care of
their people doing this for their people
why is it the the the answer you have is
different I said what do you mean well
it seems like you're hard on people
[Music]
I said no man I'm not being hard on
people
I'm just trying to take care of my
environment
I'm not trying I don't practice being a
a dik
I'm trying to take care of my
environment my decisions are about my
environment right so little Grant it
little grants this this little phone
right here this is little Grant he got
issues he needs to clean up his issues
Grant's got to get hard on Grant okay
you you guys out there y'all y'all so
soft on your people it's because you're
soft on yourself
right that's why you end up with no
money you end up with people betraying
you you end up with people taking
advantage of you even your kids don't
appreciate you do you got to be hard on
yourself I'm hard on everybody around me
but mostly I'm hard on me I'm making 2.4
million dollars a year if I could figure
out how to get another 200 that's called
value add VA value ad if I could figure
out how to raise the rent 200 bucks
531 units
see that's why the number of units is so
important
531
106 thousand dollars
times what
is what one point
see that creates another one million two
hundred and seventy four thousand
dollars of income a year
I'm already making 2.4 million dollars a
year
bam
[Music]
okay I got more cash flow
I just got I don't have to go work I
don't have to beat stuff up
I don't have to go Uber you guys are I'm
gonna go Uber to what what are you gonna
Uber to
you end up with seven dollars
[Music]
same energy folks same energy
spend the energy going someplace getting
a vehicle that can actually get you to
Freedom
[Music]
I don't want money this money I've had
this money here the whole time okay it
ain't gonna do anything
how many you got money in the bank right
now
it's useless
money is useless until it is put to use
people earn money and then they spend it
and you're just doing this thing
comes in it goes out you have to have
multiple exits on the way out
how do I get out of this deal I know
people that have bought real estate that
they're like in cash flows but they're
like I cannot I can never get rid of
this piece of property it's always going
to be a problem for me hang me around my
neck
but it pays me a little bit of money
okay now if it's only one unit if it's
only one unit folks and it makes you 500
a month it's still only 500 a month
everybody agree that's why you don't
want to go small you got to figure out
how to do it big if you do it big if you
do it right if you have the right right
location the barriers to entry if you
have the cash flow that you need if you
get good debt on it I promise you you
will not lose money in this space
Warren Buffett said don't lose money
number two what
number three
exactly so when when I read that I'm
like don't lose money don't lose money
don't lose money
what do I invest in
[Music]
oh invest in something that doesn't lose
money don't speculate don't buy stocks
like I don't want to trade a piece of
paper for a piece of paper it's a piece
of paper when you go buy twenty dollars
with a Google stock what do you get
you get a piece of paperback
it's all made up
kids steal it anyway
okay I want something I can see would
you agree
okay I would rather have that that money
I'd rather take this money and say okay
here's a hundred dollars here's a
hundred dollars I'm gonna take the
hundred dollars and I'm gonna buy a flip
chart
this flip chart is more valuable
than that hundred dollars
if I use it
everybody agree okay so I want you to
write this down quit saving money
the banks have brainwashed you
saving money save your money save your
money save your money the the Wall
Street also did this stay liquid stay
liquid stay liquid you want liquidity no
you do not want liquidity you want to be
illiquid and you do not want to save
money people should be studying the most
successful companies in the world not
not individuals don't don't worry about
Dave or Gary or Tony or Grant what are
successful people doing you know I the
one of the biggest mistakes I've made in
my life was tracking
people that were doing better than me
[Music]
Dave did it or The Millionaire Next Door
that that book
I don't want to be The Millionaire Next
Door I want to know what Jeff Bezos is
doing I want to know what the boys at
Google are doing okay why why does a guy
like Mark Zuckerberg go from college
dorm room to one of the richest people
on the planet
that's who we should be studying and and
don't listen to everybody else
because those people have Financial
Freedom to the point to where they they
can do anything they want like you
cannot mess up some of these people's
situations
they couldn't screw it up if they wanted
to
so uh the 10x rule is is a it says hey
look you want to scale to a point
to where you have the life you deserve
it's not about the money you want or the
money you need scale your business so
you can walk away from it and money
never stops taking care of you and your
family you don't need to study 27
different warrants
you study one more and you're probably
going to be good most of us because of
Instagram and Facebook and YouTube we're
listening to so many different people
that that people do nothing
this this is a new crisis of our era
people are doing nothing not because
they're lazy because they have data that
is conflicting so if you listen to Dave
Dave says buy a house then you listen to
grant grant says that's stupid you're
not going to do anything
and if you're never going to buy any
real estate hey go ahead and buy one
house yeah you're going to regret it
later and you're gonna be like I wish
I'd have done what Cardone said but but
you got to do something and what you
don't want to do is listen to God and
the devil
because then you get stuck in purgatory
and you don't have any fun at all you
need to dream big I mean you cannot
dream big enough
telling you you can't dream big enough
you can do more than you're doing
but you can't do more than you're doing
if you hang around with little thinkers
that could be your family members could
be your friends could be the people
you're going to school with and hanging
out with look there's a time and a place
to hang out with those people
can't pick your family I mean they say
you can't I wonder sometimes we don't
actually do the picking and just show up
there but I'll say that for another
conversation
but I do know once once you get with
your family the family that you picked
or they picked or however that might
work the selection process wherever you
went to school or go to school or where
you grew up or how you grew up or
religion you grew up in or whether
you're white or black or brown
male or female the question's always
going to be
what can you do
to do more with your life to find your
mission to find your purpose
to find what you're great at to get
great at the things maybe that you're
not great at that you don't even like
doing number one think big
telling you you can do more and you will
do more than than you ever imagined if
you're ever successful in your life that
you ever hit it and you can you will
look back 10 15 20 years from now and
say God what was I thinking
what was I thinking I promise you
you know it's like 80 pounds of weight
looks like a lot
when you're five or six years old later
it's pretty easy to pick that up
no matter what your frame is as long as
you do the work as long as you do the
work and show up in the gym one day
you'll be able to pick that barbell up
just like in life okay the things that
you think are impossible today the
things that you hate today the things
that you aren't good at the things that
you think are a waste of time the things
that make you angry
are all opportunities for you your bank
money right now is earning point zero
zero two five percent
my real estate's earned at 20 percent
if you have no place to go you see when
I was 26 years old I was broke 27 I was
broke 28 I was broke 29 I was broke 30 I
was broke you know why because I take
the five grand and I'd push it off to
the side and I was broke again hustling
to go get another five grand why because
I knew where I was going I was going
here
I'm like I'm Gonna Be A Millionaire dude
ain't nobody gonna take this deal from
me and I am not going to wait till I'm
90 years old to get the million bucks
right by the time I'm 33 years old I had
1 million one hundred and twenty five
thousand one hundred and twenty seven
bucks in the damn account one million
125 127 33 years old and I started with
no money at 25. how
I got the five thousand I don't need to
go buy something yet I gotta add that
every year now I need to learn how to
get that money to grow
twenty percent a year
it'll take me 20 years
to get it done how did I get it done in
eight years
I must have either added money
or earn more than 20 percent
and it was a combination of both how do
you do that
you don't do it at your job
you can't go you can't be a waitress
making you know 40 000 bucks a year and
all of a sudden make twenty percent more
it's your job you can't like it just
doesn't you can't just all of a sudden
say I'm 20 better give me 20 more money
and even if you could you'll do it one
time not every year
Francisco it cannot be such a good
cameraman that he's like hey dude look
give me a 20 raise this year all right
can he do it again next year sooner or
later I'm gonna be like
tapping out dog okay your photos aren't
that good I mean they were good but now
they're getting expensive look buying a
Jet was something I never dreamed I'd do
I never okay I only started thinking
about it four or five years ago when I'm
young and broke I'm growing up in
Louisiana middle class being told be
grateful you got a bike get a bike be
grateful you got clothes on your back
and you get three meals be grateful for
all that you got cause you got it better
than I do I never dreamed to have my own
damn Chestnut whatever you have to do to
keep your purpose burning hot you
you borrow money okay use money if it
requires money so be it if you're truly
obsessed it will be worth it because you
will get the results you know the secret
to sustaining the obsession is a
straightforward one Focus your efforts
on everything that will fuel you for the
long run and ignore eliminate and block
out anything that drains you or causes
you doubt money power Fame success all
all of them follow attention
to what gets the most attention is what
will grow the problem with these things
is money power Fame and success even
time off they they require attention
they're like jealous lovers they need
constant attention or they're going to
leave you how you invest your time is
more important than how you invest your
money being obsessed with your sense of
purpose across every part of your life
will allow you to accomplish all the
things you desire I think most people
are not accomplishing what they want in
one area life because they quit on all
the other ones if you quit on all the
other ones how you gonna get this one to
run nothing inspires me more than
surrounding myself with people who have
achieved more than I have and then
meeting new people I need the obsessed
must surround themselves with people you
trust and respect who think big who've
done bigger than you and who can help
you get to where you want to go you
think you can run only so fast time is
no longer an excuse because the obsessed
make time they don't make excuses five
grand is a doable deal how do I do it
it's 412 dollars a month
okay I got to go steal the money I can
steal five thousand you could steal five
grand for me and I wouldn't even know
it's gonna be like
if you could add five thousand to that
and earn twenty percent it'd be worth a
million 125. if you could do this at ten
percent be worth 320. some of you small
thinkers out there be like dude I'll
take the 320. how do I get 10 and how do
I get 20. you guys have figured this out
you're like [ __ ] if the play is big
enough dude I'll figure that out
everybody agree see what I just I
shifted your mind by giving you a Target
I don't go to Target I get targets and I
keep targets and I refresh the Target
and the target is I want to be a
millionaire but over the period of time
I got 20 years by the way what would pay
me 20 a year over 20 years
and that is when your boy GC
got rich
I didn't get rich speaking I didn't get
rich selling books
I got rich shopping real estate
30 years old shopping every weekend dude
every weekend all I did between 25 and
30 years old was make money make money
make money and push it aside push it
aside push it aside even when in the
first years when I was not watch this
even when I was not
25 years old five grand boom next year
five grand
boom next year five grand boom guess
what next year oh by the way this
money's sitting dead in the bank
is that not only anything it's it's in a
it's in a holy account
holy means okay I'm gonna put a hole in
your face if you're touching my money
nobody could get this money this was not
like sacred account okay you with me 28
oh wow man I could add a little bit
maybe there's more money 29. what am I
doing right here okay one two three four
boom I got 25 000 sitting in an account
it wasn't a million dollars and I'm five
years into the plan
but when I was ready to start investing
money I started doing my homework 30
years old
homework
shopping properties 31 homework shopping
properties 32. I'm not buying cars you
guys are buying cars flying on jet
Charters showing off going on vacations
all I'm doing is stacking paper guess
what happens I have five years of
putting five grand away next thing you
know I had twenty five thousand dollars
to add to my twenty five thousand
dollars next year I'm making more money
I got twenty five thousand dollars you
see what I'm doing I'm stacking dough
and looking for twenty percent
I know there's a 20 play out there some
of this money was sitting in the bank
this is years and years ago where the
bank would pay me six or seven or eight
it didn't matter that's not the target
the target is to get to 1 million
remember this and let's open up the
calls okay your job is to find a vehicle
that can pay you 20 a year might be a
business might be the business you're in
it might be to buy advertising for the
business or brand you're in for me it
was this I'm going to buy real estate
that over long periods of time I will
earn cash flow okay it's how the real
estate works
I put 25 000 in a deal
that deal is probably going to pay me 10
a year
you said yeah but Grant you said what'd
you say Grant would you say
20 man that's what you said yeah I know
what I said this ain't Eddie okay now
how much do I have I could reinvest that
money back in the deal the next year I
have 27 000
500.
[Music]
I earned 10 on that
it has 27.50 or something like that
I reinvest that now I got 30 000 in the
deal
okay but what you don't know is the the
rent on this property as I own it over
20 years
2038 will dispose of this thing the rent
is going up as I'm adding money the
rent's going up and maybe this goes from
10 percent a year
[Music]
by the time I sell I want to be at 20
okay my average deal has paid me over 30
percent a year
so when you start taking money and start
compounding it like that
for long periods of time to trick is
long periods of time I'm 19 years old
and I run a consulting firm
s telling you real estate stuff and I
have only about 60 grand for what I've
done skate up yeah and do you think I
need to still wait till 100 Grand to
invest in real estate how long you had
60 Grand uh for just like 12 months now
yeah dude like you got to get the other
40 bro it's an arbitrary number I just
made up the number it could be 110 it
could be dude it's just it's just so you
know first of all when you get to 100
call me and I'ma probably tell you hey
man you need to wait till you got 350.
at least then you're gonna be like you
know what I learned how to make I
learned how to not just make a hundred
save a hundred and put a hundred away
people are investing too soon there you
guys are investing three grand here two
grand over here a thousand bucks 500
you're walking away from it it's never
worth any money it's dumb
or create the discipline what you end up
with is a bunch of losses
rather than knowing I have the
confidence that I can make money set it
aside protect it
right protected like a kid
[Music]
right
it's not going to get in a wreck I don't
lose it
I would do that first
so is there an age I didn't invest my my
first investment was five thousand
dollars then I blew it
and I'm like I'm not doing that again my
next investment is going to be big where
I'm going to watch it
because if it's big enough dude if your
life depends on it you'll get up in the
morning Jen you'll watch it
so my next deal was 350 Grand it took
three years to do it all I did was save
money save money save money I put 350
Grand in the deal sold that deal for
four million dollars a four million
dollar profit
I had I had one third of all my money in
that deal I had a million dollars like a
million one put 350 in my first deal 30
days later put 450 in a second deal 90
days later put all the rest of my
Capital 100 of all my money Plus 90
grand
in three real estate deals
the first three Investments I ever made
my the first three or four Investments I
made in my entire life
three of the four did the little one did
the little one couldn't work
it's impossible to work it was too small
What's it gonna do
it's not gonna do anything
it's like going into a casino and you
bet fifteen dollars
right you get blackjack
so what's still fifteen dollars the
first thing you're going to say is dude
I should have bet everything
but you didn't shouldn't even be in
there and if you want more 5 espresso
videos check out the one that we
recently did the link is right there
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there